a day in the life of the bacteria in
your gut they are on a different
schedule from you because you're eating
and it's taking a certain amount of time
for you the bacteria to make their way
this is the bacteria are all in the
large intestine which is the end of the
line
well the rectum is the end of the line
but but this is this is a place where
your your body's kind of done with
everything you absorbed in the small
intestine even sorbed all the nutrients
that you can that that your body's going
to use and the stuff that they don't
want it's kind of stuff that you throw
into the composter the large intestine
that's the composter that's where the
bacteria live and they can use them
they're like oh I'll take that so the
back they call your bacteria down there
and in your colon and they're waiting
for you to be done done with what you're
gonna do with it and then it's passed
along so it's a certain amount of you
know it's like five hours before you're
sort of you know me it's making its way
and coincidentally that's the peak in
flatulence is about five hours after a
meal and the other bacteria are kind of
doing their thing because flatulence is
gas produced by bacteria breaking down
whether it's usually sugars of some kind
like lentils and beans being the most
famous contributors anyway so they are
they're happily doing their thing so
there are there on a lag from your
schedule so whenever you're eating then
you sort of wait a while and then
they're eating and I don't know exactly
what else they do with their lives in
there I don't know how they pass the
time in between and I thought how much
fighting is going on I think that it
seems to me like a lot of gang tribe
warfare going on because you know when
you hear about a fecal bacteria this is
if you were a you are a gut bacteria and
suddenly here comes this whole it's this
you know population giant population of
foreigners you know so it's this other
crazy immigration situation where
there's they're duking it out and the
strongest ones win and so that's a
global whole global warfare scene going
on but on a day to day life in the colon
it's probably pretty mundane it's very
centered around food a little bit of you
know reproduction yeah this is a pretty
soon it's a simple life I think
Pleasant probably Pleasant the
temperature weather is great it's very
uniform it's kind of like kind of like
the Bahamas in there it's very - the
tropical breezes I guess no no a little
bit of the breezes